i'm greg gutfeld i'm martha mccallum i'm
brett bear and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday august 31st 2022
i'm dave anthony
she's the latest member of congress to
go to taiwan
amid all the chinese threats and war
games around the island we know that
china is intent on being globally
dominant by the time we get to the
midpoint of the century we talked to
republican senator marsha blackburn
i'm lisa brady the latest trump court
fight could have much bigger
implications for the federal government
i do think that there's a need for
greater oversight of the fbi we have a
long history of proven bias by fbi and
justice department officials
and i'm tommy laron i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
china
will be playing more war games this week
this time with its ally russia joining
in after all the military exercises and
live fire drills china's been conducting
all around taiwan they're trying to turn
up the temperature to a degree where it
becomes sort of this new normal
we've said publicly we're not going to
accept it national security council
spokesman john kirby it began as an
angry reaction to house speaker nancy
pelosi's trip earlier this month to
taiwan an island china considers its
territory we will not abandon our
commitment to taiwan and we will proud
of our enduring friendship that the
democrat says has lasted for decades 43
years ago
with the taiwan relations act america
made a bedrock promise to always stand
with taiwan
and on this strong foundation we have
built a thriving partnership that
includes u.s military support now since
pelosi's trip several other members of
congress have visited taiwan
the last one there was senator marsha
blackburn just the other day what i
expected to see is pretty much what i
saw senator blackburn is a republican
from tennessee people who
love
love their country
people who are very patriotic who share
our values of democracy of freedom of
liberty
of individuals being able to be
productive china is really trying to
bully not only taiwan but the other
nations that are there
in the pacific island region in the
indo-pacom area as we call it
you referenced it as a country and the
nation you said when you talked to
taiwan's president that you referenced
it as a country
that of course goes over very badly with
china china considers it its own
territory a rogue breakaway region
essentially
the us has strategic ambiguity toward
taiwan but you call it a country
yes i do call it a country because when
you look at the fact that they have a
founding father they have the
constitution
they have all of their cabinet their
military i think it's appropriate you
know and think about it like this if we
recognize them and their independence it
makes it much more difficult for china
to go in and run over them and say no
this is our territory and we have to
have the one china policy
and think about it from their
perspective how does the u.s recognize
those countries that broke away from the
soviet union and established their
independence and set up their government
drafted a constitution
moved forward with electing their
president
and that's the kind of respect that the
taiwanese would like to see okay now do
you think that we should change our one
china policy then we should just
say taiwan is its own nation period
i i think it's time to review that
review
uh the way nixon and carter
moved forward on this track and say how
do we best help taiwan to defend
themselves how do we best stop
chinese aggression not only
in the indo-pacific but across the globe
because we know that china is intent on
being globally dominant by the time we
get to the midpoint of the century all
right now when you talked to the
president of taiwan for weeks china had
done all these military drills around
the island
and these war games and exercises angry
over the pelosi visit was was she
concerned that there is going to be an
invasion or some sort of a
attempt to take it over
i i think the best thing to say is they
are very watchful and very mindful
and they are watching the aggressiveness
of taiwan
of uh china against taiwan and meeting
with the president with their national
security council with the foreign
minister
they are all looking at how they bolster
their defense posture
how they prepare in the event that there
would be a conflict
making certain that they're going to
have the ability to purchase
from the united states
through the foreign military sales
program what they need to protect
themselves okay so you
president biden had said that the u.s
would defend taiwan
if china were to go on the attack he
sort of backpedaled on that but do you
think he made the right statement
initially
i i think that
when you look at his history
throughout all these decades in the
senate he has been supportive of taiwan
when you look at how they fumble things
with ukraine i'm one of those that had
encouraged
the white house to move forward
with selling to ukraine what they needed
to defend
themselves in the event of a conflict
and i
i wish that they had and i think looking
now at how russia came at ukraine that
taking a preemptive action and helping
them bolster
what they needed to defend themselves
would have been helpful
to forestalling uh any kind of attack
this is one of the things where our
allies need to know that they're our
allies and our enemies need to fear us
it's it's been more than six months
since the invasion
there is a counter offensive going on
this week in some areas that russian
forces had taken over i want you to hear
what president zielinski had said he's
vowing to chase the russians to the
border
this will happen this is ours and just
as our society understands it i want the
occupiers to understand it too there
will be no place for them on ukrainian
land now senator you've been to ukraine
you went three years ago as a member of
the armed services committee way before
russia ever stormed in
what's your assessment of the conflict
now
i i think the ukrainians have put up
much more of a fight
than ever was expected
and
people have been encouraged by
their tenacity and their ability to
protect their their land
my hope would be
that they are able to continue to push
against russia and i think it's also
important for us to note in this
discussion that china
russia
iran and north korea that comprises your
new axis of evil as i call it and what
you see
is russia
beginning to do exercises military
exercises with china right right they're
starting that this week i believe right
aren't they doing these joints that is
right at the same time you see iran
another participant in that axis of evil
stepping up and saying hey russia if you
need drones if you need some isr
capabilities come to us we will be happy
to sell these to you
so
we need to keep our eye on this and look
at that relationship between russia and
china look at the relationship of how
china is
using russia
to help china push to their their goal
of global dominance you also on this
trip to taiwan you also stopped at the
solomon islands correct yes i did now
that's of course closer to australia but
there wasn't a situation where
suddenly they do not want any foreign
ships and to make a entry into their
ports they recently entered into a
security arrangement with china what
does that mean
it is a tremendous concern and one of
the things that was
of note to me during this trip is those
pacific island nations they look at
australia new zealand and the us
as their traditional partners
and for the solomon islands now
to be in such close relationship with
the chinese communist party is causing
concern to many of the political leaders
there in the solomon islands and many of
the religious leaders in the solomon
island
and actually
the political leaders have formed what
they call
the opposition
the people of the solomons will tell you
the u.s
is their preferred
partner they prefer
doing business with the us one of the
things they say about the chinese
communist party coming in
is that when they come they bring
chinese workers they do not work
with the local people and the solomons
do not appreciate that
they would like to have that work for
their citizens
so
i assume then you with all this
discussion whether it's the solomon
islands or taiwan or working with russia
you would agree
with a lot of the assessments then that
that china is our number one threat
oh yes i do think that china is our
number one threat and the way they are
practicing the belt and road initiative
the way they're practicing debt
diplomacy you see them moving into
africa when you go to djibouti
uh where they went in and said okay we
will give you technology
and they put cameras so that the
jabutans could be viewed on camera with
the comings and goings and then china
says oh by the way
we would like access to your port
for doing this so they set up a
commercial port and the next thing you
know they've set up a navy base
so
they're doing the same thing when you
look at what they've done in sri lanka
you look at what they're trying to do
down in south america this is a push to
put their naval bases
and their infrastructure
in place as they push to global global
dominance and when you look at the debt
diplomacy some of these countries where
they've gone in with technology or roads
eighty percent of that country's debt
will be held
by the chinese communist party
senator marsha blackburn republican from
tennessee back from a trip to taiwan the
other day thank you very much for
joining us thank you
[Music]
this is tommy laron with your fox news
commentary coming up
the fbi raid on former president trump's
florida estate has spawned ongoing
reviews of the documents seized in
addition to court fights but the white
house continues to take a hands-off
approach we have not been involved
in this matter as a part of the justice
department's ongoing criminal
investigation spokeswoman karine
jean-pierre telling reporters monday
that president biden has not been
briefed she would not say whether he
would get a briefing when intelligence
officials finished their review of
documents taken from mar-a-lago we're
just not going to comment about
conclusions we're not going to comment
on anything related to this at this time
any specifics the former president and
many of his supporters consider this
part of an ongoing witch-hunt texas
republican congressman ronnie jackson
just another example of the rules don't
apply in this particular case because
it's donald trump trump's lawyers still
want a third party a special master to
review the documents a recently unsealed
affidavit cites classified materials
previously recovered as the basis for
this month's search warrant the trump
team is concerned in part about
privileged information the justice
department says its own team has already
finished looking for that and found a
limited amount but there's a court
hearing on the motion for a special
master tomorrow well it's not a moot
point there's no question that
the request for a special master should
have come from the trump team the day
after the raid jonathan turley is a fox
news legal contributor and law professor
at george washington university by the
same measure i've written in columns
that i thought that the attorney general
himself should have
supported such an appointment it's one
of the modest proactive steps
that mayor garland could have taken to
assure
skeptics in the public that this is
neither particular
nor political in nature
but having said that
it's not a useless exercise
clearly you cannot get that cat to walk
backwards and the doj has already seen
the documents
they've already used their taint team to
remove apparently some documents
but a special master could do a couple
of things one is to
have an independent review to determine
whether the taint team was correct about
privileged material
also the special master can
release a list of
material without compromising any
secrets it can divide up documents into
classified
covered and non-covered material
that last group could then be returned
to the trump team we may be able to
learn
how
broad this search was and also to get a
better idea about what was searched
without necessarily obviously learning
anything classified
what about the argument from trump
attorneys
accusing the justice department of
ignoring executive privilege and the
presidential records act
after some privileged documents were
found
well that may in fact be true
the
justice department itself acknowledged
that attorney-client material may have
been seized i would be very surprised as
i said after the raid
if
there was not that material
intermixed and what was seized because
the warrant in my view was ridiculously
broad i i do not believe
that the magistrate performed his
constitutional duty in signing this
warrant the warrant says that if you
find any document with any
classification marking at all regardless
of what that is even if it's
confidential you can not only seize the
contents of that box you can seize
everything stored with that box in that
room you also get to seize anything
produced during the trump
presidency that's incredibly broad and
it virtually guaranteed that you're
going to get sensitive material that the
government may not be allowed to have
there was such a build up to the judge's
order
releasing a redacted version of the
affidavit which was used as the basis
for the search warrant
were you surprised by anything in that
affidavit what could be seen of it
no i i wasn't uh including the fact that
the world did not end when it was
released
uh you know i said at the outset that
you could release a redacted affidavit
without compromising
the investigation or sources
but the media sort of mouthed the
rather implausible statements of the
department of justice that you shouldn't
release a single line from this
affidavit for those of us familiar with
affidavits in these cases there's whole
sections that could normally be released
and that turned out to be the case they
redacted a lot but they also released
a fair amount
that confirmed facts that had been
earlier leaked or released so the
government had been leaking information
while telling the court that absolute
secrecy was required
nobody seemed to notice
that
significant portions were
uh released
without
this parade of horribles that the
department of justice said would occur
and once again i view that as a failure
of merrick garland you know he could
have supported the release of this
affidavit without being forced to do it
he could have supported the appointment
of a special master without being forced
to do it at every occasion where he
could do something even a small
something to assure millions of
americans he's refused to do it and at
the same time he shows uh some degree of
of irritation that people are
questioning the integrity of his
department well you have to earn that
trust you can't just demand it
is there any chance that public
pressure
played a role in the judge's decision to
unseal the affidavit even in redacted
form
it's hard to say you know the magistrate
was subject to questions about his own
involvement this is a magistrate that
had made uh
comments about
president trump very negative comments
in social media and had earlier
reportedly recused himself from a
trump-related case
we've never really heard why the
magistrate felt that it was appropriate
for him
to sign off on such a historic raid
i would have thought that most
judges would have recused themselves in
knowing how controversial this raid
would become
but it's hard to say if that had any
influence on
this decision what i can say is that as
we as some of us said before his order
it was bloody ridiculous to say that
an affidavit could not be released in
redacted form without endangering
witnesses and investigations or being
unintelligible
that was proven to be false by this
redacted affidavit
one thing that still seems unclear is
why the urgency in august when the
justice department knew for months about
documents at the trump estate
because of what trump had already turned
over earlier in the year
well there's a lot of inconsistencies
like that it doesn't mean that they
had no reason to conduct the raid it
doesn't mean that the raid was uh
unlawful or abusive but
the narrative of the government tends to
fall apart once you get beyond
uh its initial statement i mean for
example you know you have that timeline
you know we have a timeline where
material was turned over
after the first subpoena there was
obviously communications between the
team and the fbi
and we don't really know what happened
between june 8th and august 8th that
changed that dynamic
but there's consistency problems in some
of what the government has said here now
there's also problems in what the trump
team has said i mean they we have not
seen this declassification order that
they have cited the national archives
and some of these filings indicate
that there were demands for material to
be turned over that
obviously were not complied with so
there's inconsistencies on both sides
the white house says they've had no
briefings on this including president
biden
um does that sound like normal
white house procedure in a situation
like this
it does but you have to read between the
lines in washington i mean quite frankly
most of us have been following the leaks
just like the white house you don't have
to give a formal briefing
for the white house to find out this is
coming
apparently uh this is leaking like a
sieve so
the the necessity of having a meeting
entitled upcoming raid of donald trump's
home
is really not necessary to put some
people in the administration on alert
the house minority leader kevin mccarthy
has accused the justice department of
being in an intolerable state of
weaponized politicization
uh you know claiming if the republicans
take back the house in november they'll
be overseeing the justice department to
leave no stone unturned as he puts it
if republicans did take back the house
what kind of oversight would you be
expecting along those lines
well frankly i do think that there's a
need for greater oversight of the fbi we
have a long history of proven bias by
fbi and justice department officials
the democratic congress has really shut
down those investigations
there's also very very serious questions
about the hunter biden
scandal you know i've been one of those
people writing
since this began
on the laptop uh and many of us were
attacked at the time
for spreading russian disinformation
it turns out that obviously it's not but
congress has shown absolutely no
interest in looking into
an influence peddling scheme that might
have brought millions to the biden
family may involve the president making
false statements to the public about his
lack of knowledge or involvement
in other very serious questions it's a
still effectively a blackout even though
the media now recognizes that this was a
legitimate story so long after the 2020
election but you know the indications
really are not good for the
administration and really reinforce the
need for oversight
i guess it's one thing though for
critics of some of these institutions to
say that there's a double standard but
it's it's next level right to say that
the fbi or the justice department are
actually being
weaponized for political purposes
i think it's right i do have a serious
problem with a lot of the attacks on the
fbi as a body
i have serious problems with some of the
overwrought rhetoric that we're hearing
um
there's no indication that the fbi as an
agency is on a biased
political mission
but having said that there is a serious
question about bias in the ranks
particularly among higher level
officials
that really could use an independent
investigation
and i don't think we should be afraid of
that uh this has now been going on for
years and you can't deny a documented
history of false statements and bias
statements coming from key officials
involved in trump investigations i don't
like this attitude that comes from many
people that hey don't mess with the fbi
department justice how dare you say
you're going to investigate that the
public doesn't have a right to know
these are their agencies of course they
have a right to know and this isn't just
coming out of the head of zeus this is
well documented problems within these
agencies and it does not appear that
they it have been fully addressed
law professor and fox news legal
contributor jonathan turley thank you so
much for your time
thank you is my great pleasure
[Music]
and in other news i'm gianna delosie is
that purring ball of fluff in your house
a cuddly kitten or an invasive alien
species it depends who you ask a
respected polish scientific institute
has classified domestic cats as the
latter citing the damage they cause to
birds and other wildlife naturally
that's not sitting well with cat people
who are showing their claws to the
biologists from the polish academy of
sciences he entered the cats into that
database bojack solars told the
associated press that the database
already had nearly 1800 other species
listed with no objections the uproar
over invasive alien species number 1700
he said may have resulted from some
media reports that created the false
impression that his institute was
calling for farrell and other cats to be
euthanized comments on the academy's
facebook page see people saying the
institution's classification is simply
stupid and harmful with one saying you
suck and are unworthy of your name
solarz even had to square off with a
veterinarian on tv arguing that cats
kill about 140 million birds in poland
each year as far as categorizing cats as
alien the institute noted that felis
katus was domesticated probably around
10 000 years ago in the cradle of the
great civilizations of the ancient
middle east making the species alien to
europe from a strictly scientific point
of view the institute also stressed that
all it was recommending was for cat
owners to limit their pet's time
outdoors during bird breeding season
solars admits he's a dog owner for the
fox news rundown i'm gianna zelosi
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind it's come to this
folks new york has banned the sale of
whipped cream canisters to those under
21. fines for doing so range from 250 to
500 bucks now this law wasn't made to
take the joy out of your favorite
dessert but rather because young people
are increasingly using whipped cream
canisters to get high this odd yet very
popular method of getting high involves
huffing nitrous oxide which is that
propellant used in whipped cream
canisters they are known more commonly
as whippets and they come with a very
long list of potential side effects such
as loss of blood pressure fainting heart
attack o and even sudden death long-term
effects also include memory loss and
psychosis so needless to say whipped
cream of all things has become quite the
problem you know i'm not sure if
limiting the access with an age
requirement will solve this problem but
it is rather ironic that you have to
show an id to buy whipped cream but not
to vote just saying i'm tommy lahren and
you can listen to all my hot takes at
foxnewscommentary.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download listen and be inspired with
lauren green's lighthouse faith fox news
religion correspondent lauren green uses
her wealth of stories to take the
listener on a unique journey of
spiritual discovery subscribe and listen
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes